Couple of announcements first.
Um,
it looked like the personality
assessment program got overloaded on the
due date.
I presume that was because a large
number of people in the class,
we're doing it in the last two hours.
So I've recalibrated the due dates.
The earliest due date is a week from the
previous due date,
which I think is the 23rd and then I've
divided it up by your last name.
So you should've got an email from me
telling me,
telling you when the personality
assessment is in fact dupe.
So those of you from a to h or something
like that,
have to hand it in first,
but you still had an extra week so that
shouldn't be too bad.
There's also no class on Thursday.
I have to be out of town.
So that's the announcements.
Okay.
So today we're going to talk about a
personality trait,
which is agreeableness and one end of
the distribution and something called
sometimes called antagonism on the other
end.
MMM.
It's difficult.
It's a difficult trait to conceptualize
in my estimation.
It's always been the one that's puzzled
me the most in some ways.
And I also think it's the one that gets
most obviously troublesome at both ends
of the spectrum.
So extremely agreeable.
People are empathetic and Compassionate
and compliant.
But the downside of that is that they
are not that good at standing up for
themselves and their,
and so they're often manipulated and
pushed around.
Um,
for example,
they're not as good at negotiating for
their own salaries.
And that's something we'll discuss in a
little bit.
And my experience clinically as being
that agreeable people,
the consequence of their compliance is
that they tend to be resentful because
just because you're agreeable and
compliant doesn't mean that at some
level of your psyche you're not
interested in a fair deal.
And if you're not particularly good at
negotiating for yourself,
especially in the presence of
disagreeable or antagonistic people,
then you're going to be left with the
short end of the stick.
I think the typical complaint of someone
who's very agreeable is I do so much for
other people and they seem to do so
little for me.
And so if you feel that way,
mmm,
there's a reasonable probability that
you're agreeable,
there's some probability that you're too
agreeable and maybe you should stop
being so easy to get along with.
And that's one possibility on the other
end of the distribution,
the antagonistic end,
well,
if you're antagonistic enough,
he ended up in prison.
It's the best personality predictor of
antisocial behavior.
It seems to be associated with sorta
cold blooded aggression rather than the
reactive form,
which would be more characteristic of
negative emotion neuroticism.
So,
and I think that people who are lower in
agreeable,
denser,
higher antagonism are probably
predatory.
Now,
you know,
human beings are predators and we have
been for a huge swatch of our
evolutionary history,
maybe for all of it,
you know,
maybe not when we were one cell down and
most,
but for a huge,
a huge chunk of it.
And during that time,
our capacity to be predators is
definitely been key to our survival.
Um,
we perhaps started to cook 2 million
years ago.
It's very peculiar human activity,
you know,
the use of fire and cooking and there's
no other animals that do that.
Um,
it made me much more digestible for us.
It shortened the length of our digestive
system a lot.
So if you look at human beings compared
to chimpanzees,
you know how to chimpanzee has shaped a,
they're sort of shaped like this and
it's because a chimpanzee is mostly in
test dines.
And the reason for that is because they
mostly leaves.
They do hunt though they will catch
monkeys,
but they mostly leaves.
And so most of what a chimpanzees life
consists of is sitting around chewing
leaves and then digesting them because
leaves are not particularly nutritious.
Whereas human beings,
we figured out how to hunt very
effectively and then we figured out how
to use fire and fire makes almost
everything more digestible and increases
the Ph,
the caloric efficiency of the food and
it in it in particular it meat makes
meat more digestible.
And so that meant that we could decrease
the length of our gut and increase the
length of our,
the size of our brain,
which seems like a pretty good trade off
fundamentally.
So
anyways,
before we can talk about this,
I'm going to go over something perhaps I
should have gone over before,
which is a bit of elementary statistics.
Well,
they're not so elementary because people
dispute them continually,
but I want to talk to you about the
normal distribution because you're going
to run into this in,
in it pretty much in every science,
but particularly in psychology because
most psychologists will tell you that
most things in the world are normally
distributed.
That's it's not exactly obvious why that
is.
It's all so not obvious by the way that
that it's true.
There are lots of things that aren't
normally distributed.
Money is not normally distributed.
Productivity at work is not normally
distributed.
The number of books people publish is
not normally distributed,
nor is the number of records people
record or the songs that they write or
the paintings that they make.
Virtually anything that has to do with
productivity is distributed in a prieto
distribution,
which we'll talk about more towards the
end of the class.
And a premio distribution is a
distribution where most people,
at least in the human case,
where most people have or do very little
of the productive work in a very small
minority,
do virtually all of it.
And so,
um,
it's a vicious distribution and it's
much more common than you'd think if you
went through the average psychology
training program.
I didn't really learn about premio
distributions till about 10 years ago.
And then it was because I had a client
who was a financier and a and a
psychologist at the same time.
And he taught me a lot of things that I
didn't know,
which was quite convenient.
So anyways,
back to the normal distribution.
Psychologists will tell you that things
are normally distributed and almost all
the statistics that you will encounter
are predicated on the assumption that
the data that you're manipulating is
normally distributed.
Now you're supposed to check that
assumption before you engage in this
statistics.
And if the data isn't normally
distributed,
there's various things you can do to it
too,
too deep to make an approximate a normal
distribution before you do the analysis.
Although sometimes you can do,
I think real conceptual and empirical
damage to the data by forcing it into a
normal distribution,
especially when it's one of the things
that actually isn't normally
distributed,
which aren't theoretically aren't
supposed to exist,
but which do.
Now this is,
let me show you some,
some something about a normal
distribution and this is,
this is a golden board.
That's what this thing is called and
golden was this incredibly intelligent
polymath from the late Victorian Times
who made contributions in a whole
variety of scientific disciplines,
psychometrics being one of them.
The measurement of human behavior,
a golden is often regarded as the first
person who studied intelligence,
but that's not true.
Actually gotten studied what he called
Eminence and Eminence was sort of the
probability that you'd be in the same
class structure,
say as an aristocratic Englishman,
and he thought of that as an inborn
trait,
you know,
which made the British aristocrat
superior to the British commoner.
And then of course superior to everyone
else as well.
And people confuse that with
intelligence.
But if you read golden carefully,
you find out that he really,
he didn't conceive of intelligence,
it was more like talent or ability while
or eminence,
which is what he called it.
So now golden was interested in
measuring things.
And so he made a lot of measurements of
people,
various aspects of people,
physical aspects,
and he started to develop some of the
presuppositions that we use in our
statistics today.
And one of the things he noticed was
that a lot of things that you can
measure,
like height are normally distributed,
which is to say that most people are
average and there's a distribution
around the side so that most people are
average.
A few people are really tall and a few
people are really short and it's kind of
a continuous distribution across,
across that entire span.
And so that's a normal distribution.
Now the theory is that things are
normally distributed when a lot of
different factors contribute to them.
So you can imagine in the case of
height,
well what,
what might contribute to it.
Um,
prenatal conditions might be one.
Nutrition might be another genetic
heritage might be other.
Another,
which you could also divide into the
genetic component you get from your
mother and the genetic component that
you get from your father posture.
Um,
gender,
those are a few,
maybe ethnicity.
The Dutch,
for example,
are extremely tall.
Um,
so there's a variety of factors that
might contribute to height.
And when a variety of factors contribute
to something,
then it tends to be normally
distributed.
That's the hypothesis.
And so now it's because the variation is
random.
So let me show you what it means for
variation to be random.
Now,
so golden figured this out.
Now this is a golden board.
Now a go when a golden board would
normally be,
would be a board with nails.
So each of those little dots there,
you imagine those are nails and then it
would be slanted a little bit.
And then there'd be a spout at the top
right in the middle that would drop
marbles down.
And then at the bottom there's a bunch
of containers where the marbles could
land.
And then you can see how the marbles
distribute themself if you let them fall
randomly.
Now this is random because at each nail,
imagine a nail is a choice point,
right?
The marble can go right or left and it's
entirely random.
And so here's what happens.
If you run something randomly,
now you can see as the ball's accumulate
or the marbles accumulate that they're
starting to be considerably more in the
center and considerably fewer out on
that edges.
Now the technical reason for this is
that there's lots of ways to get to the
middle and hardly any ways to get to the
edges,
right?
Because if you want to go all the way to
the right for example,
then you'd have to,
yeah,
here we go.
If you wanted to go all the way to the
right or the left,
then every time you hit a nail,
you'd have to go either,
right?
So write,
write,
et Cetera,
or left,
left,
et cetera.
And you can imagine since there's only a
0.5 probability of each of those,
that once you have 10 or so of those
stack together,
the probability that you're going to
take that particular path is vanishingly
small where there were in the middle.
There's all sorts of different ways you
can there,
right,
left,
left or right,
right,
left,
or while you get the picture.
There's all sorts of ways.
So there's more paths to the center.
Then there are paths to they had just.
And so that's why you get a normal
distribution and the normal distribution
does some pretty weird things.
So for example,
we'll go to this next one.
This is another kind of golden board.
And uh,
you know,
we'll run the first part of it and
you'll see that you get your typical
normal distribution.
So you could imagine that each of those
little nails is a factor in some sense,
a random factor determining where you
end up in the distribution.
Okay?
So after,
after we fill this up and we have a
normal distribution,
then you see the little yellow and black
line there.
We're going to take that out and then
the balls are going to fall again.
What do you think will happen when they,
when they go to the next level and it
guesses?
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's one hypothesis.
The bolts will be more likely to go to
the edges.
Anyone else?
What do you guys think?
Be More flattened.
More flat.
And people don't agree with that.
Okay.
So,
okay,
you better withdraw quickly.
It's starting to stack up here.
So,
okay,
let's see what happens.
Oh,
Lo and behold,
if we kept running this,
you'd,
you'd get another normal distribution.
So it actually doesn't change it a bit.
So the normal distribution has a pretty
robust phenomena.
So
now if you're doing basic statistics,
let's go back to that for a minute.
What you're really trying to do is to
figure out
what the probability,
yeah,
what the probability is that two
distributions will overlap.
So for example,
let's say you took the distribution of
height among women,
which is about five foot four on
average.
And so there'd be a,
you know,
a normal curve around that because
there's some very short women and some
very tall women.
And then there'd be a normal
distribution around men and men are on
average five foot nine.
And then you could calculate the
probability that those two curves were
the same by chance.
And that would depend to some degree on
the number of people in your sample.
So to do this statistics,
you need the two normal distributions,
you need the number of people in the
sample,
and then you need a way of calculating
the probability that those two
distributions could have been drawn from
the same population.
So that's your hypothesis.
Basically that's the null hypothesis is
that the two samples are drawn from the
same population,
in which case there's not going to be
any difference between them or there's
going to be random differences between
them.
And the cut off point is that if you're
to populate,
if the two samples you draw have normal
distributions that overlap,
that overlap in such a limited manner
that that would only happen in one of 20
cases.
Right?
So you're drawing random samples from
the population,
then you presume that that's a
significant difference.
Now it's arbitrary.
That's P is less than 0.05 it's
arbitrary.
Now you might say,
well why did psychologist picked P is
less than 0.05 and answer to that is
there.
There is no reason except that there's
all,
there's two areas that you can make when
you're calculating your statistics.
One error is you find a difference when
there is,
when there isn't one right?
You find a difference when there isn't
one and the other is that you don't find
a difference when there is one and those
are type one and type two errors.
And what you're trying to do is to
minimize both of them simultaneously.
And that's that's you.
You can't say where that's most suitable
because by reducing one error you
increase the other.
So psychologists had to pick some cutoff
and 0.05 seem to be as good as anything
else.
So
now here,
here you want to look at this because
actually you really need to get familiar
with what a normal distribution looks
like and the ways that it's parsed up.
So you see right at the center,
that's the mean and the median and the
mode if the,
if the distribution is perfect and
normal,
those three things are going to be the
same thing.
Um,
at the,
the next level there you see percentage
of cases.
So at three standard deviations below
the mean,
there's only 0.13% of the population
that's three standard deviations below
the mean or three standard deviations
above the mean.
So we could say we can think about Iq
because people are sort of cognizant of
Iq to some degree a hundred which would
be the mean in terms of Iq is the
average Iq of someone who's your typical
high school graduate.
And then 115 is the Iq of your typical
state school graduate in the u s so
there's a difference of 15 points.
And that corresponds.
If you look here in terms of
percentages,
which is the the,
you know the bottom line is 50% of
people have an Iq above 150% have an Iq
below and it's,
it's because it's defined that way by
the way.
And then if you go up one standard
deviation,
you see that pretty well.
It's we'll 85% for the sake of
simplicity.
85% of people have an Iq below 115 and
then if you go up to two standard
deviations,
you see that 98% of people have an Iq.
Okay?
Below two standard two standard
deviations and three standard deviations
is 99.9 so when you get up to 130
there's only two and a half percent of
the population has an Iq that high.
That's about where you guys are
somewhere between 120 and 130 so you
know,
you look around and you think,
well you know this is an average class
of university students,
but you're not average in terms of
intelligence.
And that makes a huge difference because
intelligence is one of the best
predictors of career success.
For example,
do you grow up to three standard
deviations?
That's an Iq of 145 you know when
there's undoubtedly a couple of you in
here,
um,
well there's,
it's one in a thousand in the
population.
There's a couple of you in here that
have an Iq of 145 or maybe more than a
couple.
Now,
one of the things you want to notice is
because people get very confused about
this with regards to percentages.
So let's say that you were assessing to
people to hire them,
or you were assessing them for their
intelligence,
which is something that might be done.
For example,
if you were screening them to go to
university because the sats do that in
the u s or if you were screening them
using the graduate record exam and you,
you'd have you at one candidate who's
98th percentile and then other candidate
who's 99th percentile.
Okay?
So think about that for a minute.
98 99 where's the,
where is there more difference?
You have three candidates,
one is 85th percent to all one's 98th
percentile,
one's 99th percentile.
Where's the biggest difference?
Is it between the 85th and 98
yeah,
in terms of of improbability.
So it's the same distance.
Now that's what you have to remember
when you're thinking about percentiles
because 99 to 99.9% I'll don't sound
very different,
but they're the difference between one
and 101 in a thousand so it's a huge
deal.
That's why you see that the normal
distribution is divided up into these
standard deviations and those are
basically identical differences and
those are often identical differences in
terms of ability.
So for example,
you know,
you might think that once you hit one 30
going above that isn't going to matter,
but that's not right.
There's just as much difference between
someone who has an Iq of 130 and someone
who has an Iq of 145 as there is between
someone who has an Iq of 115 and an Iq
of 130 even though the percentile start
to switch around.
So you need to know these sorts of
things if you're,
when you're starting to think
statistically because otherwise while
you can't understand what you're doing,
and that's,
that's generally not a good thing.
So although it's very frequent,
okay,
so agreeableness is one of the five
dimensions of the big five.
We all know that.
And it can be broken down into these two
aspects,
compassion and politeness.
And so you can kind of figure out how
agreeable you are by looking at these
items.
They're all positively scored for the
sake of simplicity.
So if you intensely feel others'
emotions,
if you're always in inquiring about how
others are doing and you actually care
rather than doing it for the sake of
show,
if you,
if you're capable of sympathizing with
other people,
if you respect authority,
if you don't like to see him or be pushy
and you don't like to impose your will
on others,
then you're an agreeable person.
And a disagreeable person or
antagonistic person obviously is the
opposite of that.
So they're in don't feel peoples'
emotions very profoundly.
They're not really all that concerned
automatically about how other people are
feeling and they're not that
sympathetic.
Um,
it's funny cause in my clinical practice
I can tell the difference between the
agreeable people in the non agreeable
people because when the agreeable people
come and they have a cup of coffee,
they always bring me one.
But when the disagreeable people show up
and have a cup of coffee,
they only bring a cup of coffee for
themselves.
So it's quite comical actually.
So now you might think that,
you know,
cause our,
our,
what would you say our society is at the
moment,
tilted towards regarding agreeableness
as a virtue.
You know,
because you should be kind and you
should be empathetic and you should be
compassionate and all those sorts of
things.
But our research,
this isn't published yet because it's
complicated to,
to communicate and we haven't figured
out how to do it yet.
But what we've found is that if you push
any of the,
um,
traits too far,
they fall off a cliff fundamentally.
So if you get too agreeable,
then you're dependent and you can't make
decisions and so on.
And maybe you're kind of afraid.
And Eda pull mother too,
right?
You're so,
you're so,
uh,
concerned with your,
with your child's wellbeing that you
can't,
you're not harsh enough to send them
outsider or make them do anything they
don't want to do because it might upset
them.
And so that's not so good.
And then if you're to disagreeable while
I already said what that was like,
if you take antisocial people who were
in prison,
you know,
they're,
they're aggressive and violent and you
know,
the criminal types and they're,
they're predatory,
are low in agreeableness.
So you can see how that's a bad thing.
But then in the middle range,
it,
it gets more complicated because then
agreeableness that where you're located
on the normal distribution,
how good that is,
depends to some degree on what it is
that you are going to do.
So one of the ways to think about how to
maximize your success in life is to
attempt to match your personality to the
environment.
And so now what we're gonna do is we're
going to look at how agreeableness plays
out as far as we can tell in the actual
world.
No,
this is,
I should tell you too,
this is the sort of discussion that
really people really don't like.
Everything we're going to talk about
pretty much from here on end rubs people
the wrong way because our culture is
very,
um,
likely to assume that most of the
differences between people are cultural
in origin and almost none of the data
show that what they show is that right
as at least as your culture becomes more
egalitarian,
which is hypothetically what you're
aiming at.
The differences,
gender differences for example,
not only become more biological because
you've eradicated all the cultural
difference,
but they also become more pronounced.
So for example,
the gender differences between men and
women are largest in the most
egalitarian societies like Norway and
Sweden and so on.
And so the theory there is that well
once you've eradicated all the
environmental differences,
all that are left are the genetic
differences.
And so that's sort of echoed in a weird
finding in families.
So you know,
you might think that if how you raised
your children mattered.
Okay.
And children who were raised well would
be more similar than children who were
raised badly cause that would reflect
the effect of your parenting.
Right?
So you've done a good job as a parent.
So your children are more similar where
someone who just ignored them,
those children are different.
But that's actually the opposite of what
happens is that the children that are
neglected are more similar.
And the children who are attended to
well are more different.
And the reason for that I think is the
same reason that we see more pronounced
differences in need galitary and
societies,
which is if you care for your children,
it means that you make a very individual
relationship with each of them.
So you're not necessarily using the same
strategies for each child unless you
think of them as Meta strategies.
And like I met a strategy might be,
well I get to know you and I get to know
you.
And because you're different people,
I react differently to you.
And what's what constitutes my
philosophy of parenting would be act
differently towards the children's
differences.
And so maybe if you're particularly good
at that,
your children turn out maximally
different from one another.
And that's because you're allowing their
genetic differences to manifest
themselves.
You know what oppressing them,
you know,
and trying to cram them into the little
box that you think that they should fit
it.
Now the downside of that is that you're
going to get differences,
you know,
and some of them might be quite
surprising to you.
So
all right,
so let's look at some gender differences
to begin with.
So women are half a standard deviation,
more agreeable.
So we looked at the standard deviation.
So,
um,
half a standard deviation would
represent,
let me see if I can figure it out here.
So
50 smoke,
34,
so 1767,
the average woman would be,
have to be
less agreeable than 67% of women to be
as disagreeable as the typical mat.
So that's,
that's the basic size of the effect.
Okay,
the difference.
Now you see,
now you see how the two distributions
overlap,
right?
So what the first thing you can see is
that in the middle of the two
distributions,
there's a space and that's a space
that's filled with men and women.
So most of this space is occupied by men
and women.
But if you look off to the right,
say,
the most agreeable women,
the most agreeable people say three
standard deviations from the mean.
They're all women.
Well,
that might not be that relevant,
but if you go to the left,
all the people who are three standard
deviations below the mean are man.
Now that really starts to matter.
And here's one way it matters who's in
prison.
Most men,
now you don't throw anyone in prison
unless they're like three standard
deviations below the mean in
agreeableness,
which would put them at about one in a
thousand.
In fact,
more people ended up in prison than
that.
But the point is,
once you get out on that edge,
then the gender differences become
absolutely staggering.
And that's,
that's a weird thing about normal
distributions,
right?
You can have a very little mean
difference because the mean difference
here isn't that big.
It's only half a standard deviation.
It's not that massive.
But as you move out towards the
extremes,
the effects accumulate and they have
huge societal effects.
So the cl here,
and I can't remember what that stands
for,
the probability that a randomly drawn
woman will be more agreeable than a
randomly drawn man is 63% now women are
also higher negative emotion and the
difference isn't quite as big,
but it's,
it's roughly comparable.
So fundamentally the two big gender
differences are in agreeableness.
So women are more compassionate and
sympathetic and empathetic and less
confrontational.
And then negative emotion and negative
emotion is anxiety,
emotional pain,
frustration,
disappointment,
they all kind of clumped together into
one
axis.
So the agreeableness dimension
seems to be stable across the lifespan
that the gender difference,
where's the neuroticism difference only
seems to emerge in puberty for women and
then it stays constant pretty much for
the rest of the lifespan.
So,
so this is one of the things this means
is that the probability that a given
woman is more agreeable than a given man
is.
It is about 63% and then also in terms
of negative emotions,
say it's approximately the same thing,
but then you might think,
well,
what's the probability that a given
person will be higher negative emotion?
And more agreeable.
And then you see how,
because these dimensions are orthogonal,
right?
They're unrelated essentially.
So that means you can add them together.
And so once you start to add the
personality differences together between
men and women,
they actually start to become come quite
big,
far more than half a standard deviation.
Women are also more extroverted than
men.
So that's funny because extroversion,
extroversion is a positive emotion
dimension,
whereas neuroticism is a negative
emotion dimension.
So,
but women are more extroverted too,
which means they experience and display
more positive emotion.
And that seems to be the aspect of,
of extroversion that seems to carry most
of the gender differences,
enthusiasm rather than assertiveness.
And so women laugh more than men,
for example.
So when,
when,
you know,
there's an old cliche that women are
emotional,
more emotional than men,
and that actually seems to be the case.
If you look at negative and positive
emotions specifically conscientiousness
also sing seems to be linked to emotion
to discussed into shame and the guilt.
And there's no,
there's very little gender difference
there.
So it isn't like women are more
emotional than men across all the
emotions,
but the gender differences are larger
and more egalitarian cultures.
While the thing is,
this is starting to become difficult to
dispute because the size of these
studies is starting to become extreme.
So this one study,
Schmidt at all,
uh,
they studied 18,000 people across 55
cultures.
So that starting to become a pretty
impressive,
you know,
a pretty impressive sample.
Um,
UN indices of gender equality and
economic development were associated
with larger gender differences in
agreeableness,
but not an extroversion or neuroticism.
So,
so that's interesting.
So the,
the,
the effect of egalitarianism doesn't
seem to be spread across all the gender
differences just in terms of
agreeableness.
So,
and gender predicts more powerfully than
gender equality.
Now the,
these are interesting studies and you
know,
I,
I don't think that that the theorists in
the humanities have really caught up
with them because there's a huge,
there's a huge stress in the humanities
and modern universities on the idea that
gender differences are cultural in
nature and can be eradicated by cultural
transformation.
But the evidence seems to suggest that
the only way you could eradicate them by
cultural transformation would be by
working very,
very hard against the biological
substrate.
And you got to wonder if you really want
a society to do that,
you know,
like what kind of society do you want?
Do you want a society where everyone is
allowed to be who they are,
so to speak,
and to be successful at that?
Or do you want a society that does
everything it can to make people the
same regardless of their individual,
you know,
of the individual differences that are
intrinsic to them.
It is by no means obvious that that's
what you want.
So you'd have to do some pretty wicked
social engineering to eradicate
differences.
And it looks like the social engineering
that you'd have to do would run counter
to egalitarianism.
Right?
Because he,
since egalitarianism seems to heighten
the differences,
it only makes sense that you'd have to
run counter to egalitarianism to reduce
them.
So,
okay.
The lippa study here where,
where there's an association between the
UN indices of gender equality and gender
differences in agreeableness.
I think that was 500,000 people.
So the,
you know,
the net has made,
uh,
the Internet has made it possible to run
huge samples.
Now here's some interesting things to
um,
the,
the occupational preferences between men
and women are actually a lot larger than
the,
than the personality differences and the
occupational differences are large and
not,
and like the gender differences in
personality,
the occupational preference differences
increase as you move towards more
egalitarian societies.
So the big difference between women and
men seems to be that women prefer
working with people and men prefer
working with things.
Now it's an interesting way look at it
because for a long time,
you know,
if you're thinking about sexist
stereotypes,
say up till the 1950s,
maybe a little later than that,
maybe up to the mid sixties or so.
Um,
the idea would it be in that whatever
gender differences there were in an
occupational,
uh,
skill in,
in,
in occupational distribution would have
had more to do with skill that was so
that,
you know,
men were more skilled,
say at engineering and women were less
skilled at it.
But what seems to have been what seems
to be the case is that if you look at
the basic predictors of success,
like intelligence and conscientiousness,
there's virtually no gender differences
at all.
Now.
So what that seems to mean is that the
reason that there are occupational
differences,
at least in egalitarian societies is
because the occupational differences are
driven by choice,
not by ability.
Now that's something to think about.
You know,
because again,
that seems to indicate that if you're
going to push hard against gender
preferences,
what you have to do in some sense is
restricted degree to which people's
choices determine their occupational
outcomes.
And you know,
and once again,
it's not exactly clear that you'd like
to live in a society that would do that.
I mean it,
unless you think that precisely quality
across every dimension in terms of
occupational,
um,
what the number of men in the number of
women in each occupation is such an
important index that it actually trumps
what people as individuals actually want
to do when you allow them free choice.
So,
so the big difference is,
and it's one standard deviation.
So to be as interested in things as the
typical man,
the typical woman would have to be more
interested in things than 85% of women.
And to be more interested in people than
things to be as interested in people as
the typical woman.
A man would have to be more interested
in people than 85% of men.
And that's starting to become a very
large difference.
Now there's other differences too.
This is using the Holland categories.
Holland is a very well renowned
industrial organizational psychologist
and he divided jobs into these six
categories,
realistic,
investigative,
artistic,
social,
enterprising and conventional.
And what you see is that men show
stronger,
realistic,
and investigative interest.
The realistic category is particularly
big.
It's eight tenths of a standard
deviation.
And women show strong artistic,
social,
and conventional interests.
And there was no sex,
no gender difference at all in the
degree to which people prefer an
enterprising occupations.
So
here's from the,
from a different study from
psychological bulletin looking at
there's,
there's this,
there's this phenomena that,
that people are quite upset about,
especially in the u s although it's also
an issue in Germany that women are
underrepresented in science,
technology,
engineering and mathematics dimensions.
And so,
but if you look at the interests of men
and women,
you see under men that men are 1.1
standard deviation,
more likely to be interested in
engineering and three,
four tenths of a standard deviation to
be more interested in math,
science and three tenths of a standard
deviation,
more interested in math.
Now that has,
again,
that has nothing to do with ability.
So you know,
for there there is some evidence,
although it's really highly disputed and
the evidence I think keeps going back
and forth,
that men are better at spacial rotation
and that seems to be linked to
testosterone.
But I,
like I said this,
this idea has been attacked very
heavily.
Um,
there's also some evidence that if you
look at the intelligence distribution of
men and women,
that the women women's distribution is a
little higher peaked and little less
wide.
And what that means is there's far more
men who fall into the extremely
intellectually impaired category.
And that sort of seems to go along with
the fact that the vast proportion of of
children in school who are in trouble,
our boys,
but they're also overrepresented at the
extreme upper end of the continuum.
So the mail distribution has flattened.
And the people who believe that believe
that,
well,
it's typical in animal communities,
mammalian communities,
for them to be more variability among
the man.
So because men are expendable
fundamentally,
and so in some sense the species can
take a bigger chance with variability
even though the means remained the same.
Now that was what Larry Summers was
referring to.
He was a prison president of Harvard
when he suggested that there might be
intellectual differences between men and
women.
That in part accounted for the
differences in,
in stem,
um,
prevalence.
And he just got roasted for that.
In fact,
I think they fired him,
which was really unfair.
I thought because he was just referring
to a study.
He wasn't making a claim that that was
his opinion.
But,
but we can put that aside for the time
being.
It doesn't look like you need to invoke
an intellectual capacity explanation to
account for the underrepresentation.
You can just see that in the interests
diverged.
Now you know,
you could attribute that to stereotypes
and so forth,
but then you run against running up
against the problem that the differences
are bigger in the countries that have
done the most to eradicate the
stereotypes.
So I don't really see how that's
hypothesis can survive as far as I'm
concerned.
It's just been proved wrong in the last
10 years.
The gender differences are not primarily
cultural.
So,
so then you see this underrepresentation
here,
um,
completing degree in employment in math,
50% fewer women in math,
40% in the physical science is 25% the
computer science and 25% in engineering.
So
here's other occupational differences
that,
that are quite extreme.
And then there's other reasons for
these.
I don't think that these are only
interest related.
So let's say what other differences,
what are differences between men and
women?
Just once,
right?
There's the primary and secondary sexual
characteristics.
What else is different?
Adoption.
Okay.
These jobs are more dangerous kind of
jobs.
Yes.
Well that that goes along with this sort
of nail expandability issue,
right?
So yeah,
they are board dangerous jobs in the
probability that a man will be killed at
work is extraordinarily higher than the
probability that a woman will be killed
at work.
So,
um,
what other differences are there between
men and women?
Lennar and Margaret?
Yeah,
there were about four inches taller.
They're known as much happier as you
would think.
I thought it was bigger than this.
I'll show you one 64 versus one 94.
Those are the American averages.
So here's,
here's differences between men and
women,
the gender differences,
these sort of physiological gender
differences.
The cycle of psychological gender
differences to some degree too can be
lumped under a biological category
called sexual dimorphism.
And in some animals,
sexual dimorphism is how much
difference.
The reason the morphology is between the
male of the species and a female,
if this pcs,
and there can be a lot like with the
elephant seals for example,
the males are like 10 times bigger than
the females,
usually in a situation like that,
the male has a Harem.
So there's extreme male reproductive
success on the part of a couple of males
and then extreme male failure among the
rest of them.
So there's some seems to be some
relationship between lack of sexual
dimorphism and monogamy among mammals.
So the last dimorphic,
uh,
a species is the more likely they are to
pair bond and human beings are
relatively non
dimorphic.
So we're a little are dimorphic than the
typical monogamous animal,
but a little less dimorphic than the
typical,
um,
polygamous animal and gender
differences.
These sorts of gender differences with
the male being larger and more
aggressive than the female are not
characteristic of all mammals,
although their characteristic of many of
them.
So the one,
the major,
the major exception or hyenas and the
hyena females are very testosterone
arised and they're very,
if that's a word,
they're very much,
they have very high levels of
testosterone and they're slightly larger
than the males and they are more
aggressive.
But the price they pay for that is that
their reproductive organs mimic the
penis and that's what they have to give
birth through.
So it isn't exactly clear that that's a,
I'm not sure that's an advantage.
Okay.
Well so,
so here are some of the differences
between men and women.
So you could see there's a five inch
difference in height,
a 30 pound difference in weight.
Um,
men are about 40 to 60% stronger in
their upper body in about 70 to 75.
Oh,
sorry,
that's wrong.
Women are 40 to 60% as strong as men in
upper body strength and 70 to 75% in
terms of low of lower body strength.
Men have thicker jaws,
heavier jaws.
Women who are ovulating prefer men with
thicker jaws.
So,
for example,
if you show women pictures of the same
men across their menstrual cycle and all
you do is widen the jaw,
the narrow jaw guy is more preferable
when there's less probability of
conception.
And the wider jog guy is,
is uh,
more,
more desirable when the probability of
ovulation is high and jaw dimensions are
associated at least to some degree with
aggression.
Why would that be?
Cause it's for biting.
You know,
like,
think about animals,
they bite,
you know,
and human beings can bite too.
So the jaw,
the relationship between jaw dimension
and disagreeable to say seems to have
somewhat of a hangover from our
evolutionary past.
Women have a higher proportion of body
fat.
Women are very resistant to diseases.
That's a good deal for women.
They live longer.
That's a good deal too.
There's way more male homicide victims,
which seems spectacularly unfair until
you notice that there are many more male
homicide perpetrators,
which then seems to sort of even things
out.
Um,
men kill non intimate acquaintances or
strangers,
80% of the time where women kill
intimate partners or family members,
60% of the time,
of course they're doing it a lot less
frequently.
So,
and you never know how many of those are
in something approximating desperation
and self defense,
right?
Uh,
excluding the odd psychopathic woman.
So,
um,
let's see.
Okay,
so back to these construction,
forestry,
mining,
utilities.
Well,
you can kind of see maybe that these are
jobs,
you can tell me if you disagree,
but these seem to me to be jobs that
might require more physical strength.
That would certainly be the case in
forestry and mining and construction and
likely in utility work too.
So,
and then there are also things like
jobs,
right?
So these aren't,
you know,
there's not a lot of value on fostering
close human relationships in these sorts
of occupations.
You know,
so
yeah.
So here,
here's some interesting things.
10 most dogs,
male dominated occupations in the u s so
I guess one of the things that you might
ask yourself is,
um,
do,
wouldn't you be interested in a job like
this?
So hypothetically man are more
interested in jobs like this than women.
Brick Mason block,
mason stone masons.
So you know,
carving up stone,
cement masons,
electrical power line installers and
repairs.
That's a tough job.
Aid be very hard to do that like during
the ice storm.
That would be hard job.
Carpet floor and tile installers,
heating,
air conditioning,
refrigeration,
mechanics structure,
iron and rebar workers,
bus and truck mechanics and diesel
engine specialists,
miscellaneous vehicle in mobile
equipment,
mechanics tool and die makers and
roofers.
So,
and those are overwhelmingly male,
right?
If you look on the right hand column
there,
there isn't even 1% of the total number
of women in those occupations isn't even
1% you know,
it's funny you don't,
you don't hear a lot of like gender
affirmative action calls for structure,
iron and rebar worker,
gender equality.
So what's your,
wow,
I think that's interesting.
You know,
if it's,
if it's merely a matter of gender
inequality,
then why does it differ?
Why?
What difference does it make?
What the category of employment is?
That sort of argument shouldn't be
reserved for only the upper echelons and
the most desirable jobs,
you know,
otherwise that's not a coherent
argument.
It either applies across the spectrum of
jobs or it's incoherent.
Those are the alternatives.
So here's the 10 most female dominated
occupations in the U S it's still
secretaries and administrative
assistance.
Now,
you know,
that was the most common female job in
the 1950s and it is still overwhelmingly
the most common female job.
So that's quite interesting.
Although it's incredibly dominated by
women.
So you know,
is that a good thing or a bad thing?
It's like,
it's not that easy to tell childcare
workers.
Well that doesn't really come as much of
a surprise,
but it is,
it is notable.
And was one of the things you see in the
Scandinavian countries,
for example,
it's pretty much related to this,
is that there's a,
in this,
there's a 20 to one difference,
men versus women in engineering and
there's a 20 to one women versus men
difference in nursing.
So,
and it's this Scandinavian governments
every now and then go through a fit of,
of enthusiasm about attracting more
women into engineering.
And so they,
you know,
crank up their social engineering in
there and their information about how
desirable profession that is.
And then the proportion of women who go
into engineering rises slightly,
not very much.
And then as soon as they stop,
you know,
pushing it hard,
it just drops right back down to 5%.
Teacher assistants,
registered nurses,
bookkeeping,
accounting and auditing clerks made in
housekeeping,
cleaners,
nursing,
psychiatric and home health aides,
personal and home care aides and general
office clerks.
So that's where the bulk of women are in
the,
that's where the bulk of the female
dominated occupations are.
So
let's see,
now,
did I cover all those things?
Yeah,
I did.
So
here's,
I've been trying to figure this out for
a long time.
Like what this agreeableness thing is
and this is sort of what I've concluded,
um,
because I'm always interested in tying
this down to the biology and Jaak
Panksepp has a very good neuroscientist,
is identified a number of fundamental
biological,
emotional systems.
Um,
some of which we've alluded to already
and some of which we really haven't.
So for example,
it was Panksepp who identified the
existence of a place system
for engaging,
for example,
in rough and tumble play.
And that seems to be something that
males prefer more than females prefer,
but he's also identified a care system.
And you could think about that as the
basic it there has to be a care system.
I mean,
for God's sake,
we're mammals,
right?
I mean,
the definition of a mammal is,
well first the mammal is warm blooded
and has hair.
But the next part of it is that the
mammal is fed breast milk.
And so obviously there's a dependent
relationship there and it's not only a,
like it's a dependent relationship and
it's a difficult dependent relationship.
You know,
like children are very,
um,
not able to care for themselves for a
very long period of time.
I don't remember if I mentioned to you
this or not,
but a mammal of our size should carry an
infant for two years gestation.
So you should be pregnant for two years
and then the baby would be born.
And would be,
you know,
good for something walk round.
And so like,
like many mammals can as soon as they're
born.
But because our heads are so big and
because women's hips have to be narrow
enough so that they can run,
there's an evolutionary arms race
between the structures in some sense.
And so what's happened is that,
you know,
women compromise by having wider hips
and babies compromised by having heads
that can be be compressed during
childbirth and also by being born much
earlier.
But the price that's paid for that is
that they're incredibly dependent.
And so,
so when you think,
well,
okay,
there has to be,
well it's foolish to even argue
otherwise.
People fall in love with their bayberry
babies to a staggering degree.
And the typical response of new parents
is,
well,
I never knew it would be like this
because even if you're not interested in
someone else's baby,
you tend to be unbelievably interested
in your own baby.
And that's a good thing because there
are a lot of trouble.
And so there's a system and maternal
system,
primarily a care system.
It's a system that's shared by men
because men are also very maternal for
mammals.
And so I believe that's on the one end
of the agreeableness spectrum.
It's like the maternal care system is
what's driving empathy and sympathy and
all of those things.
And you know,
I think actually that it was the,
it was the expansion of the maternal
care system to include men that actually
resulted in human beings capability to
pair bond.
Because one of the things that's really
weird about people is that they share
food because animals aren't very good at
that.
Like chimps,
we'll do it a little bit,
but they're not too happy about it.
And wolves sort of look like they share
food,
but that isn't really what happens.
The dominant ones just eat until they're
full and then they don't mind if you
know the subordinate ones eat what's
leftover.
But human beings will share a food.
Now,
of course,
female mammals often share food with
their infants,
but they don't generally share food
with,
you know,
their,
their compatriot.
And you know,
you think about all the,
think about the language that couples
who were in love use to each other.
You know,
there's a real infant tile element to
it.
It's baby and deer and you know,
they make little cooing noises and they
give each other a little pet names.
Like there's something that's,
that's like there,
there's,
there's a juvenile element to it that it
seems to me to be a consequence of the
activation of this care system,
you know,
between adults rather than from the
adult to the child.
And so,
anyways,
then on the other end,
well,
there's a predatory aggression system
and I think that they've,
they've come together in evolutionary
history to balance each other out.
So both men and women are carrying and
predatory,
um,
women more caring and less predatory and
men more predatory and less caring.
But both genders have that both
capacities within them.
And I think they've evolved so that they
are mutually inhibitory,
so that a predatory male is not that
likely to kill infants,
whereas,
and,
and fairly likely to care for them.
Now there are exceptions to this,
you know,
and,
and they're not trivial.
So for example,
stepchildren are much more likely to be
killed,
especially if they're under two.
You are at 100 times more risk for abuse
from a step parent than you are from a
natural parent.
And so you see echoes of this in the
animal kingdom too.
So for example,
if a girl has have harems and then of
course one gorilla has,
you know,
offspring with a variety of female
gorillas and all the adolescent grillers
is sort of outside that little circle
just waiting and tapping their feet for
the guy in the middle to get tired or
hungry or you know,
exhausted so they can come and run in
there and you know,
overthrow him.
Fundamentally when they do that,
they kill all the infants and so to
lions,
so
no predation and care systems,
you know,
they're very tightly balanced and they
are influenced to a large degree by
genetic similarity.
Rough as that is.
So
in caring professions,
5% males,
let's look at predation.
8% of the male population hunts exactly.
Quite large number.
When you think about how many people are
urban,
right?
Because it's hard for,
what are you gonna we'd get hunt
raccoons,
you know,
I mean once you're in an urban
environment,
it's not that straight forward to hunt,
but in a rural environment it's,
it's you know,
right there for you fundamentally.
So it's only 8% of the male population
in the u s that hunts.
But you know,
you have to factor the urbanization
issue in their 91% of those people are
male.
So hunting isn't something that
generally appeals to women.
So
now
what other reasons might there be for
the gender differences?
Well,
this is more speculative than what I've
discussed with you so far.
So you can think about it.
I mean these are the things I'm trying
to get straight and so I'm going to
share you share with you some of the
pathways of my current thinking.
So there is evidence that more
disagreeable people are more likely to
be successful as managers.
Now,
why?
Well Boudreau who wrote a paper called
effects of personality on executive
career success,
said the following,
agreeableness associates with being
trusting,
submissive and compliant,
which could be perceived as naivete
docility and a tendency to follow rather
than lead.
All right,
so that's his opinion.
But then here's what he measured.
So these are effects of five traits on
career success.
Now,
you know,
career success can obviously be defined
a number of ways.
It could be career satisfaction or it
could be like external markers of career
success.
And,
and they did both.
So we're going to look at direct cause
that's the external sort of objective
markers weren't you see is that if
you're high in neuroticism,
that's not so good for how much money
you make.
There's a negative correlation of 0.3,
which by the way,
that's a big correlation.
So you know,
you'll hear people say that 0.5 is a
large correlation and 0.3 is moderate
and you know,
point to a small and that's wrong.
And that that was clarified four or five
years ago.
Um,
I'll get the paper for you.
I can't remember.
It was an American psychologist,
but the guy who wrote the paper,
what he did was he looked at a whole
bunch of social science studies and then
calculated how frequently different
effects sizes showed up.
And what he found was that 0.5 was
unbelievably large.
You know what,
if that 5% of social science studies
ever got a correlation of 0.5,
it's like if you get a correlation of
0.5 and your study,
you've either made a dramatic error or
you've replicated something that's
already well known or you know you're in
science because it never happens.
Point three,
that's a pretty good correlation.
So,
okay,
so the fact that neuroticism is
negatively correlated with how much
money you make,
how likely you are to ascend,
and then how close you are to being ceo.
Obviously the effects size decrease.
So,
um,
neuroticism is oss,
or sorry,
extroversion is a reasonable predictor
only of how much of your ascending and
it's pretty small.
Um,
openness has a correlation with how much
money you make,
but that's probably because openness is
highly associated with intelligence.
And so openness is not a good marker for
intelligence.
Iq tests are much better markers.
So that's an attenuated relationship.
But then you look at agreeableness,
okay,
it's negative 0.3,
two in total,
put negative 0.2,
four for direct in terms of how much
money you make.
So you know,
that's an interesting thing because one
of the things that determines how much
money you make is how willing you are to
say no.
Right?
Cause if you're negotiating with someone
then
the only thing you have at your back is
your ability to say no and to push it or
even to ask for a raise.
And you know,
pushy people are much more likely to ask
for race.
And of course those who ask for a raise
are much more likely to get it.
So the guys who were hard to get along
with,
because most of the people that were
hard to get along with,
our guys are more likely to be paid
more.
They're more likely do as sand the
corporate ladder.
They're more likely to be close to the
CEO in terms of proximity.
And,
uh,
they're even more likely to be rated as
employable.
It's funny because you'd think that,
you know,
if you're agreeable in easy to get along
with and all that,
that people would be more to rate you as
a suitable employee.
But that is right.
That's the opposite seems to happen.
So you know,
in the agreeable guys are less satisfied
with their jobs.
No,
sorry,
the agreeable people are less satisfied
with their jobs as well.
So,
okay,
so now let's look at motivation
variables.
So the extroverts work more evenings.
The agreeable people,
the uh,
agreeable people are less likely to,
okay.
So it's a funny thing too because
disagreeable extroverts are narcissists
and there's some evidence that you can
derive from this data.
You don't,
cause there's always this talk about
disagreeable extroverts are narcissists
being more likely to rise up to CEO
level.
And there is some evidence for that,
at least in so far is agreeableness is a
negative predictor of doing such.
All right.
So,
so one of the things we've just found is
that one of the predictors for
ascendancy and proximity to a high
status position is low.
Agreeableness.
Now,
the next thing you might think about is,
well,
what,
what role does that play in terms of the
factors that men and women find
attractive at each other?
So you might say,
well,
what do you want in a mate?
If you're a woman,
you might say,
well you know,
you want someone who's kind and loving
and forgiving and empathic and those are
all good things.
But,
but it isn't necessarily the case that
the empirical studies show that that's
what drives mate selection.
So we could look,
this is an interesting study.
So it's a few years old,
thousand French Canadian respondents,
433 males and 700 females.
And so here are,
here are the variables.
One is possession of resources.
It's a composite index composed of
occupational prestige,
income and education.
And then the other variables,
acquisition of partners,
sexual partners,
that is number of lifetime and
proceeding year sexual partners.
Lifetime occurrence of simultaneous
partners says yes or no variable and
lifetime frequency of simultaneous
partners,
one to five with five being very often.
Here's the assumption.
You can,
you know,
decide for yourself if you think this is
a warranted assumption.
The number of partners,
a member of sex,
a acquires is taken as an index of how
often this individual is chosen by sex
b.
So that's an indication of re
reproductive fitness,
desirability,
at least as assessed by members of the
opposite sex,
who you would think would be the logical
judges for that sort of thing.
Male criteria
166 on attached
women ages 25 to 50 correlation between
fertility rates,
a number of partners and previous year
equals 0.94 males choose fertility
indicators,
beauty waist to hip ratio,
youthful appearance,
and neotenous facial features.
Neotenous means there's a tendency among
animals as they evolve to increasingly
look more in their adult stages,
like their juvenile forms.
So here's,
here's an example.
If you look at the skull of a baby
chimpanzee,
it looks almost exactly like the skull
of an adult human.
So what's happened is we've as adults,
we're more like baby chimpanzees then
than the adult chimpanzees are.
We've,
we've,
we've maintained a lot of our juvenile
characteristics,
playfulness,
you know,
the ability to continue to learn,
plasticity,
all those things.
Um,
there's a preference in our objective
beauty analysis,
say a facial features for men to prefer
more neotenous female faces.
So,
and you can tell that if you look at
pictures of models,
they generally have relatively small
noses,
relatively big eyes.
The sort of things that are associated
with cute and cute actually is a pretty
pretty identifiable category.
Most of the things that people find cute
have large eyes and relatively the rest
of their facial features are relatively
small.
There's other things that are associated
with cute that aren't necessarily
associated with,
you know,
sexual attractiveness cause cute things
also have sort of random movements like
baby,
like movements.
And so the things that people,
you know,
relatively short arms and just think of
a teddy bear.
So anyways,
those are the male,
those are the male criteria,
female criteria,
all respondents correlation between
socioeconomic status and frequency of
simultaneous partners.
For men it was 0.49 that's a big
correlation.
For Women,
it was 0.04 that's a zero fundamentally.
So the correlation between male
socioeconomic status and frequency of
simultaneous partners is 0.5.
It's a huge effect for women at zero.
And that's a big difference.
So,
you know,
one of the things you might ask yourself
too,
I don't know if this is a reasonable
thing to ask or not,
but
I've always thought that
the hard people to explain,
or the people who are hyper achievers,
you know the ones who are way out on the
Frito distribution and there aren't very
many of them and they're usually,
they're usually man,
you know.
So if you look at the media num number
of publications,
for example,
that a female academic makes had a male
academic,
they're pretty much the same,
but the mean for men is higher.
And that's all driven by a small subset
of men who are way the hell out in the
prieto distribution.
Now you might ask,
well,
why is that?
Well,
it's simple.
If you want to be way out on the prieto
distribution,
so you're in the top,
say 1% of performers or even one 10th of
1% of performance,
what do you have to do?
Well,
first having an Iq of like 145 or above,
that's really helpful.
Then you should be insanely industrious.
So maybe you'll work 90 hours a week or
a hundred hours a week at nothing but
your stupid occupation.
And maybe we'll do that for like 50
years.
And so if you do that while you're going
to be in that top one in 1000 category,
well
the issue isn't why there are so few
women in that category.
The issue is why are there any men at
all in that category,
right?
Cause it's,
it's an insane lifestyle in many ways.
You know,
um,
it,
it means that there isn't much left
there for the rest of your life.
You're hyper concentrating on a single
thing.
Now why would men do that?
Well,
here's the hypothesis.
One of the things that drives the
probability that a woman will find a man
attractive enough to sleep with his his
status.
So then you can think,
well,
that's an extra motivational boost for
men.
Now,
whether that's conscious,
motivational boost or not is not the
point.
The question is,
is it a,
is it a boost that might have been
instantiated as an evolutionary element
of general motivation or men are more
competitive,
they're more disagreeable,
and if they're more disagreeable and
more competitive,
they seem to do better,
especially in high status jobs.
And then women are more likely to pick
man like that for sexual partners.
So it's at some point it becomes
difficult to avoid the conclusion,
especially since we know that the man on
the way out on the tail end of the
prieto distribution are
disproportionately likely to sleep with
many women.
So Warren Beatty,
I think 15,000 that was his estimate,
15,000 women.
And uh,
Kareem Abdul Jabbar,
the basketball player,
he figured 10,000 so,
and so for the,
for every one guy who's got those
numbers racked up,
that's 10,000 guys who don't.
So the male success distribution is
extreme and it's associated with outlier
success in some important dimension of
socioeconomic economic success.
And then female rep productive
opportunity is not.
So,
you know,
is that relevant?
Well,
you know,
it depends on how you think.
It's hard for me to see that it can't be
relevant.
So questions if the question,
the higher the job,
like the higher status,
the more partners they have.
Oh Yup,
Yup.
Slowly and then,
but this,
this is a single study,
but this data is Coleman.
Now there's,
there's some interesting correlates of
this.
So for example,
you might say,
why are males much more likely to be to
engage in homicide?
And Daly and Wilson figured this out a
long while back.
And what they showed was very,
very cool study.
They took
the level of income inequality in each
county,
in the u s and in Canada.
And then they correlated that with the
homicide rate.
And what they found was that the higher
the rate of inequality,
so the more people at the bottom and the
fewer people at the top,
the higher than male homicide rate.
And the correlation was
okay
0.8 something like that.
Point eight five it was like,
it's the whole reason.
So what happens is that when the
competition between men gets intense
because hardly anyone can win than males
start to kill each other.
Okay.
Now daily,
also Martin and daily also tried to
figure it out if that was a good idea.
So they studied Chicago and what they
found was,
well most male and male homicides are
young man and a lot of them there within
race and they're often in dominance
disputes.
It's like,
you know,
maybe it's a gang thing and it's like,
well you shoot me or I'll shoot you.
It's like who's victim and who's
perpetrator is not that obvious.
So what happens in Chicago?
Well typically
the charge is plea bargain down to self
defense.
Then no one's willing to testify against
the guide because well after all he just
shot someone and then he's in prison for
two years cause that's the,
that's the sentence.
And then he's out in 18 months.
If he behaves reasonably well.
So then he's killed someone and he's
back on the street.
And guess what,
his status has increased substantially.
So you can think about it as a socio
economic slash sexual decision.
And we also know that as economic
disparity grows,
the social stability decreases.
And the reason for that seems to be,
well mostly it seems to be male on male
aggression.
And so what I,
what I think probably happens is that
if there's a fair bit of chance for men
to climb the ladder,
then only the most disagreeable of them
become violent.
But as you crank down on the
opportunities so that the competition
gets more and more intense,
the level of disagreeableness that it
takes in order to catalyze aggression
starts the level of disagreeableness
that it takes to catalyze aggression
starts to decrease until if it gets so
intense that there's no possibility for
status,
then the whole bloody society's going to
flip over because the guys at the bottom
who are like,
all the guys are going to decide that
this is a stupid game and they'd rather
flip the board over and you know,
set the markers to zero and see how they
come up in the new society.
So it's possible that
one of the things that motivates
revolutions in human society is
excessive inequality.
And the reason that that's a problem is
because it's so tightly linked to male
reproductive opportunity.
So,
okay,
look at age 30 to 39 correlation between
socioeconomic status and frequency of
simultaneous partners.
For Man,
the correlations 0.92 it's very small
land for women,
it was 0.11 it's difference between
perfect and zero.
Fundamentally,
female criteria might reflect the
tendency on the part of females to
choose high status partners during their
own peak reproductive years.
This might account for the especially
strong relationship found in men age 30
to 39 women who typically prefer men
three to eight years older than they are
would then be in their mid to late
twenties a time when fecundability.
And that sensitivity to male resources
is at its peak.
Evolutionary related hypotheses about
gender differences and mate selection
preferences were derived from Trevor's
Parental Investment Model,
which contends that women are more
likely than men to seek a mate who
possesses nonphysical characteristics
that maximize the survival or
reproductive prospects of their
offspring.
Offspring
as predicted.
Women.
Oh square accorded more weight than men
to socioeconomic status.
Ambitiousness character and
intelligence.
And the largest gender differences were
observed for cues to resource
acquisition status and ambitiousness as
predicted,
gender differences were not found in
preferences for characteristics
unrelated to progeny survival,
sense of humor or personality
when valid comparisons could be made.
The findings were generally invariant
across generations,
cultures and research paradigms.
So
any questions?
What do you think about that?
You know,
it's,
it's harder stuff as far as I can tell.
Does that,
because the character,
what we did a study that unfortunately I
never published,
we showed women,
I thought,
no,
women aren't after resources.
That's wrong.
Thereafter,
the factors that predict resources.
So what we did was we showed women a
bunch of pictures.
It was this say,
say several pictures of the same guy.
So there was several guys and each guy
was in four conditions.
The photo of each guy was in four
conditions.
Same photo,
right?
So one guy was poor and stupid,
pouring,
useless.
One guy was rich and useless.
One guy was rich and useful and one guy
was poor and useful.
So the rich,
useless guy had won the lottery and it
paid out like $4,000 a month for the
rest of his life.
So no matter how useless he was,
he couldn't all of it.
He had resources,
right?
The poor,
useless guy.
Well we don't even have to define that.
Everybody understands that the rich
useful guy.
Well that's easy to understand.
The poor useful guy worked for
nongovernmental agency.
It was a charity,
you know,
in a charitable organization.
And so he was,
he had high occupational status but low
income and that wasn't likely to change.
So then we asked women to rate these men
on a bunch of different attributes
including personality but also on data
ability basically and also on
probability of considering a longterm
relationship with someone like this.
And what else had no main effect?
The only effect was usefulness.
So the poor,
useful guy and the rich useful guy where
attractive,
more attractive to the women.
Then the two useless guys regardless of
their socioeconomic status and the women
judged.
The useful guys is higher in openness
and conscientiousness,
which was pretty smart because openness
is basically intelligence and
conscientiousness is hard work and those
are the best predictor of socioeconomic
success.
So yay women.
Good work.
Any other questions?
Yeah,
no,
it's not exactly appearance.
It's more like signs of health and
that's associated.
It isn't even that
the things that have made women
attracted to men across time are the
things that are associated with health
and therefore reproductive capacity.
So for example,
waist to hip ratio was a marker 0.68
seems to be about ideal.
Why?
Well,
it turns out that women who have a lower
higher,
huh.
I can't figure it out at the moment.
More waste than hips.
Arma are more likely to die.
For example,
of cardiovascular disease.
It's an unhealthy distribution of body
fat for women.
And so that seems to be a negative
fitness marker.
And then symmetry for example.
I mean women like symmetrical men too,
don't get me wrong,
but man are more attracted say to,
to physical health than women.
Um,
what are the markers for physical health
is also symmetry and that's associated
with beauty.
Clear skin.
All these things are associated with
health and youthfulness.
Yeah.
And that's,
that's pretty much that.
What about like,
that's a good question.
I had actually had a paper that I was
looking at that this morning,
but I didn't have enough time to include
it.
So I don't know exactly what the
predictors there are.
What do you think?
They'd be
evolutionary,
whatever,
male characteristics
you'd think so.
Yeah,
that's right.
Well,
that would be,
that would be a very useful thing to
look up.
Yeah.
Attractiveness.
Hard to say,
but hard to say.
But a quick glance at popular culture
would suggest so.
So,
okay,
we'll see you next Tuesday.